[Music]
ot monday edition pft p.m podcast also
chris sims
still here i am here he made his typical
daily post show i have to go pee you've
got the prostate of a 60 year old no
well i mean i drank some coffee and i
drink a lot of water when i wake up and
i don't know it's just the way it is
why you're drinking diet coke i needed
caffeine all right so drink the real
stuff i what's wrong with diet why would
i drink the why would i drink a bottle
of sugar why would you drink a bottle of
chemicals that's all right there's
chemicals and sugar it's either
chemicals in sugar or just can't you're
better off with sugar than chemicals
right thank you
there's one argument there goes our coke
sponsorship not diet coke
presented to you by coke
sugar and chemicals
okay uh
let's see what are we gonna talk about
um
we've danced around this issue of the
packers the saints the 49ers but we
didn't tee up today the very simple
question who's the best team in the nfc
right i go with the san francisco 49ers
i do i i can say that uh without
hesitation right now now i understand
that hey the new orleans saints if they
came to town i certainly wouldn't be
like oh my gosh the saints beat the
49ers i would never think that could
happen no i do think it's the 49ers the
saints okay and i think there's a little
gap between them and then the packers i
do just as a full team is concerned but
the 49ers hey we're all gushing about
the new england patriots defense
the 49ers are the number one defense in
football and it's by 10 yards now the
patriots are winning in scoring defense
with 7.6 points per game but the 49ers
are 11 points per game so not only is
the 49ers defense dominant just like new
england or anybody else out there their
offense is dominant too i mean their
offense is six in football and with some
of these games like we saw yesterday
they don't even have to play offense in
the fourth quarter so the stats are a
little misleading that way i just go
with the 49ers uh overall i don't think
it would be easy for them to beat the
saints but i think they would beat the
saints in a close one well and a lot of
it depends upon where the game would be
played sure i think this this upcoming
49ers at saints game week 12 week 14
something like that i think it's week
12. packers 49ers week 14
49ers saying so so we get a little bit
of a mini round robin the packers and
the saints don't play in the regular
season but at least see what the 49ers
can do against the other two great teams
in the nfc all right below that top cut
let's take those three out of them
first off but do you so would you would
you rank them that way probably i don't
want to agree with you probably 49er
saints packers yeah do you think there's
a a little bit of a gap between the
49ers and the saints as compared to the
packers and number three like i do i'd
say there's less of a gap between the
49ers and the saints and those between
the saints and the power got you okay
okay cool okay let's take those three
out of the mix who's the best team left
oh the best team left
man i mean that it's getting into a good
conversation the cowboys the seahawks
the vikings the rams
i i am going to go oddly enough i think
i'm gonna go with the dallas cowboys i
don't know why i'm saying that i'm just
kind of coming up this right here right
now now the seattle seahawks i know but
i just still think i look at the cowboys
and think they're a really talented
football team their offense is better
than years past they don't need to just
totally rely on the run game and i look
at their defense and go it's really
talented there as well so i'm going to
give them the edge uh but i don't
necessarily feel real real confident in
saying that yeah and and look i i could
make the argument for any one of the
teams yeah you know the thing about the
vikings they're eventually going to come
up against the defense it can take away
dalvin cook and i think kirk cousins is
not going to be able to get it done we
can heap the accolades on him i think it
comes down to kirk cousins or aaron
rodgers for nfc offensive player of the
month right for november right i don't
know that rogers did enough last night
maybe that throw to the back of the end
zone in prime time did it but uh cousins
has been great yes yes once you take
away dalvin cook that's when it's going
to be a real test for him they've got
some tough games coming up chiefs
cowboys on the road broncos at home then
a week off and at the seahawks on monday
night football so we'll learn a lot
about how good the vikings really are in
the next few weeks and the seahawks hey
cowboy seahawks vikings yeah and the
vikings play two of them over the next
month so we'll get an idea we've got a
little idea yeah i mean the seahawks i
understand you know hey they're six and
two and they got a better record than
the cowboys and they're tied with the
minnesota but i guess
there's a little trepidation i think
with the seahawks i mean yeah they
squeak out a win against the rams at
home where you know zerline usually
makes that field goal you know we we
talked a few times in the show the
browns game a few weeks ago they didn't
play really very great they didn't play
great in that game they're really
outplayed by the browns yes they won the
game even yesterday against the falcons
clearly they were the better team on the
field but it wasn't to where i was like
oh man this seahawks team it's so
dominant look at them go and then of
course they hit the blip on the screen
last week where they were outplayed by
the ravens at home too so um that's
where i guess you know the seahawks are
good i'm just not sure how good they are
yet here's the thing too yeah
if
greg zurland makes that 44 yard fuel go
on the thursday night in early october
the rams will be six and two and your
answer would have been
after that first cut you would have said
the rams are the best team in the nfl
probably you're right
let's not forget about the rams i mean
the rams are still really good they got
difference makers on both sides of the
ball they're really well coached they're
tough and physical as hell and you know
i know i've said this a bunch over the
last two weeks let's just not forget it
was seven to seven with them and the
49ers and they had the ball third and
goal on the one yard one foot line going
into score and didn't get any points and
that's kind of where the game changed
from that point on uh so yeah i think
the rams are capable of standing toe to
toe with anybody in football and winning
a football game so i certainly uh don't
don't forget about them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports